CATASTROPHIC GAFFE GONE ON -┘-
AFGHAN CHAOS.
THERE IS A PRO- WORKER
PROFAMILY PRO- COMMUNITY AND
ALWAYS FROM AMERICA.
WITH THE 20th ANNIVERSARY OF
9/11 JUST DAYS AWAY BIDEN
THROWS AWAY EVERYTHING THAT
HAS BEEN SPENT THE LAST TWO
DECADES, TRILLIONS OF
DOLLARS WASTED THOUSANDS OF
AMERICAN LIVES LOST AS THE
MOTHERS AND FATHERS AND WIVES
AND HUSBANDS AND SONS AND
DAUGHTERS AND FRIENDS AND
NEIGHBORS AND ALL FALLEN
HEROES LOOK ON IN DISBELIEF
AND RAGE AS THIS BUMBLING
IDIOT IN THE WHITE HOUSE
BARELY LISTED PUPPET THE WEEK
INCOMPETENT APOLOGY FOR
PRESIDENT HE RACES PRACTICALLY
OVERNIGHT ONE OF THE
JUSTIFICATION THERE EVER WAS
FOR THIS DISASTROUS
MISADVENTURE WITH THE HEAD OF
THE JOINT CHIEFS THIS MORNING
TELLING SENATORS OVER A PHONE
CALL THANKS TO WHAT IS
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW IN
AFGHANISTAN BASED WEB BIDEN
HAS DONE WE ARE MORE AT RISK
HERE IN AMERICA AND HOW THE
ESTABLISHMENT LAUGHED AT TRUMP
FOR HIS FOREIGN-POLICY
INEXPERIENCE.
THAT HE IS SO IGNORANT HE
HASN'T READ THE RIGHT BOOKS
AND DOESN'T KNOW HISTORY BUT
HE KNEW WHAT HE WANTED.
PEACE THROUGH STRENGTH AND
LOOK WHAT HE DELIVERED.
CHINA CONFRONTED, ISIS
DEFEATED, I RAN DEPLETED IN
AMERICA PROTECTED AND WHAT
HAVE WE GOT NOW?
THE ESTABLISHMENT GOT THEIR
RISK WITH THE HIGH POLICY JOE
BIDEN INTO OFFICE WEAKNESS
WHEREVER YOU LOOK CHAOS AT THE
BORDER, CHAOS IN THE
MIDDLE EAST AND IRAN IS
EMBOLDENED AS CHINA IS
EMBOLDENED AND OF COURSE
UNFOLDING RIGHT BEFORE OUR
EYES THE BIGGEST CALAMITY THE
MOST EMBARRASSING WEAKNESS OF
ALL THE ABJECT HUMILIATION OF
BIDENS AFGHAN DEBACLE.
WHERE IS HE ANYWAY AS THE
REPUTATION OF HIS REGIME AS IT
COLLAPSES AROUND HIM INSTEAD
OF LEADING OR HELPING TO GET
AMERICANS AND ALLIES OUT TO
SALVAGE SOMETHING FROM THE
RECORD -┘- WRECKAGE OF THE
POLICIES AND BUSY PLAYING
POLITICS.
IT IS TRUMPS FOR HE NEGOTIATED
A BAD BILL MY HANDS WERE
TIED.
WHERE THEY?
THEY WERE TIED FOR THE IRAN
POLICY WERE BORDER POLICY OR
ENERGY POLICY THAT HE SET
ABOUT REVERSING THE MANY HE
WAS INAUGURATED BY JUST THIS
ONE AFGHANISTAN.
IMPOSSIBLE TO REVERSE.
NOTHING I COULD DO.
SORRY.
NOW THEY TRY TO BLAME THE
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES THROWING
THEM UNDER THE BUS.
CONGRESSWOMAN JACKIE SPEAR
THIS MORNING.
>> A CRISIS OF UNTOLD
PROPORTIONS AND INTELLIGENCE
FAILURE.
WE UNDERESTIMATED THE TALIBAN
AND OVERESTIMATED THE RESOLVE
OF THE AFGHAN ARMY.
STEVE: THIS IS A CRUCIAL POINT
THEY ARE TRYING TO PRETEND THE
INTELLIGENCE AGENCY GAVE THEM
THE ALL CLEAR TO GO AHEAD FOR
THE RUSHED RETREAT.
>> THEY HAVE ASSESSED THE
AFGHAN GOVERNMENT WILL LIKELY
COLLAPSE.
>> THAT IS NOT TRUE.
>> PLEASE CLARIFY WHAT THEY
HAVE TOLD YOU THAT WILL HAPPEN
OR NOT?
>> THAT IS NOT TRUE.
THEY DID NOT I RENOUNCE A
SECOND QUESTION.
>> THAT IS NOW WITH OTHERS WHO
WERE BRIEFED SAY.
>> THE STRENGTH OF THE TALIBAN
DIDN'T LISTEN TO THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY BECAUSE
EVERY TIME I GOT THE AC
BRIEFING ASSESSMENT IT WAS THE
GRIMMEST ASSESSMENT I HAVE
EVER HEARD ON AFGHANISTAN.
STEVE: LET'S BE VERY CLEAR
THIS IS SHAPING UP TO BE A
SCANDAL OF IRAQ AND WMD
PROPORTIONS THEY ARE BLAMING
THE INTELLIGENCE FOR THIS
DISASTER THEY SAID IT WOULD BE
FINE IF WE PULLED OUT.
THERE'S NO WAY THE TALIBAN
COULD TAKE OVER.
BUT BIDEN IS LINE BASED ON
INTELLIGENCE SO IS JACKIE
SPEAR IN ALL DEMOCRATS TRYING
TO SHIFT BLAME ONTO THE
INTELLIGENCE AGENCY.
>> INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY HAS
ASSESSED THE AFGHAN GOVERNMENT
WILL LIKELY COLLAPSE.
>> THAT IS NOT TRUE.
>> PLEASE CLARIFY WHAT THEY
HAVE TOLD YOU HAVE THAT WOULD
HAPPEN OR NOT.
>> THAT IS NOT TRUE THEY DID
NOT REACH THAT CONCLUSION.
>> THIS WAS JULY 8 THIS IS
WHAT EVERYONE SHOULD BE
FOCUSED ON FINDING OUT WHAT
WAS BIDEN TOLD BY THE
INTELLIGENCE AGENCY AND DID HE
LIE ABOUT IT IN THE
JULY 8 PRESS CONFERENCE?
HE BLAMES INTELLIGENCE, TRUMP
NEXT THE DELTA OF AREA FOR HIS
DISASTER OR PEOPLE NOT WEARING
MASKS OR RACISM OR ANYONE
EXCEPT THE PERSON WHO IS
RESPONSIBLE, HIMSELF.
THAT HE GAVE THE TALIBAN
CONDITIONS AND CONSEQUENCES IF
THEY BROKE THEM AND THEN NO
IDLE THREATS BUT INSTEAD FROM
BIDEN WE HAVE NOTHING BUT
WEAKNESS AND INEPTITUDE IN
PURSUIT OF A POLITICAL
DEADLINE TO GET UP BY
SEPTEMBER 11.
AND THEN TO SEND ANOTHER 5000
TROOPS BACK IN SHOWS HOW
LITTLE POP ON -┘- PROPER
PLANNING WENT IN TO GET THEM
OUT.
HERE IS RYAN CROCKER WITH THE
AMBASSADOR WHEN BIDEN WAS VICE
PRESIDENT.
>> IT IS DISINGENUOUS TO SAY
AND THEN TO EMBRACE THE
PROCESS HE OWNS A LOCK STOCK
AND
BARREL, GUARANTEEING THAT.
STEVE: IN ANOTHER INTERVIEW
UNLESS THERE ARE GRAVE
QUESTIONS IN MY MIND ABOUT
BIDEN'S ABILITY TO LEAD OUR
NATION AS COMMANDER IN CHIEF
TO HAVE READ THIS SO WRONG OR
EVEN WORSE TO HAVE UNDERSTOOD
WHAT IT WAS LIKELY TO HAPPEN
AND NOT CARE.
HIS ATTEMPTS TO AVOID
ACCOUNTABILITY ARE SHAMEFUL
BUT EVEN WORSE, THE DISGUSTING
SPECTACLE OF THE AUTHORS OF
TWO DECADES OF DEATH AND
DESTRUCTION TO EXTRACT A SICK
VINDICATION SEEING THAT WE ARE
RIGHT ALL ALONG WITH MORE
TROOPS OVER THERE AND THEN TO
ASSIST THE NEOCON LUNATICS THE
MEDIA TRIES TO BLAME TRUMP ONE
PRESIDENT AND ONE
ADMINISTRATION THAT DESERVES
TO BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
IT IS GEORGE W. BUSH WHO
SCORNED THAT THE WORLD'S
GOODWILL FOR THE LEGITIMATE
INTERVENTION IN PURSUIT OF AL
QAEDA AND INSTEAD LYING TO
IRAQ BUT THAT MEDIA WAS
ANYTHING TO PUSH BECAUSE THEY
HATE TRUMP AND THE BRAZEN
NEOCON KEEPS GOING LIKE
BLOODTHIRSTY ZOMBIES THE DARK
QUEEN OF THEM ALL IS CHENEY
WHO SACRIFICED HER OWN SISTER
FOR HER POLITICAL CAREER NOW
TO EXPLOIT AMERICA'S
HUMILIATION IN PURSUIT OF HER
OWN TO ARRANGE PERSONAL THEN
DATA.
HOW DARE THEY AFTER ALL THEY
HAVE DONE TO THIS COUNTRY OF
THE TWISTED IDEOLOGIES THEY
WANT MORE TROOPS MORE
ADVENTURES AND MORE WAR.
BECAUSE WAR IS THE CHENEY
FAMILY BUSINESS FIGHT BY OTHER
PEOPLE'S CHILDREN FOR THEIR
OWN PERSONAL GAIN THE CORRUPT
MILITARY-INDUSTRIAL COMPLEX
BUSINESS WITH THE
ESTABLISHMENT ALL OF THEM
GETTING RICH AS THE WORLD
BURNS.
AND THEN WITH THAT CORRUPT
GROUPTHINK YOU DON'T HAVE TO
INVADE OTHER COUNTRIES TO
DEFEND THIS ONE.
YOU DO NOT HAVE TO SEND YOUNG
AMERICANS TO THEIR DEATHS TO
SAVE LIVES HERE.
PEACE THROUGH STRENGTH FOR
FOUR YEARS AND WORKED.
BUT NOW WE'RE BACK TO THE
WORST OF IT ALL